hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video
we're going to talk about is how to
convert from fractions to decimals to
percentages and any which order so what
we're going to do here in this video is
we're going to talk about this chart
right here and just whether you're given
a fraction decimal or percentage how to
convert it into the other formats so
let's start up here with five-eighths
we're going to convert from five-eighths
as a fraction to a decimal now when you
have a fraction when you see this
division bar this fraction bar can
that's really like a division sign so
this is really like five is being
divided by eight so let's go ahead and
look at that so we've got five who's
being divided by eight or how many times
does 8 go into five so if you don't see
the decimal point it's going to be here
on the right side of the number okay
five and so what we're gonna do is we're
just gonna go ahead and see how many
times does 8 go into five well it goes
in zero times does 8 go into 50 yes it
goes into 50 6 times 6 times 8 is 48
we're subtracting we get 20 okay just
bring down the zero it goes into 20 two
times okay we subtract again bring down
another zero okay
8 goes into 40 five times and that goes
in evenly so we have as a decimal point
six two five so let's go ahead and add
that to our chart here 0.625 now to
convert from a decimal to a percentage
what we do is we take that decimal point
and we move it one two places to the
right so it's just like this one two
places to the right now we have 62 point
five percent okay so you're with me so
far we're gonna do some more examples
here they're giving us the decimal point
to two now point two two is kind of like
a shorthand way a little bit of a
sleighing way of saying what this
decimal is this is actually 22
hundredths now you can see that you want
to look at the last place that the the
number has here which is the
place tens hundreds thousands right so
it's in the hundreds place so if you
pronounce that correctly it's twenty two
hundredths which means that this
fraction is 22 divided by a hundred but
you can reduce that further to eleven
fiftieth by dividing the numerator and
denominator by two so we're just
reducing it to lowest form now to go
again from the decimal to the percent
that's pretty easy we just have to move
the decimal point one two places to the
right so that's gonna be twenty two
percent okay
now in the next example they're giving
us a percentage a hundred and forty
percent how do we go from a hundred
forty percent back to a decimal well
here what we're doing is we're actually
going to be moving the decimal point to
the left two places so this is actually
one point four zero or you could just
say one point four another way to look
at it is percent per means divided by
cent means hundred like a hundred cents
and a dollar a hundred years in a
century a hundred feet on a centipede
and so on so percent you can think of
this as a hundred and forty per 100 and
that'll also help us to convert this
into a fraction okay which is a hundred
forty over a hundred and we can reduce
that to 14 over ten which is seven over
five or if you want to write it as a
mixed number one and two fifths
five goes into seven one whole time with
two left over so one and two fifths okay
let's just do a few more examples I hope
you're enjoying these videos let's take
a look at this example here two fifths
we want to convert that to a decimal
right so two divided by five so the
fraction bar means divided by so let's
go over to here two is being divided by
five 5 goes into 2-0 whole times
okay 5 goes into 20 four times four
times five is 20 with zero left over so
we can see our decimal is going to be
0.4 so this is 0.4 okay now to convert
from the decimal to the percent we're
going to move that decimal point one two
places to the right
we're gonna have to put a placeholder
here since there's not a number there so
that's going to be a zero so it's going
to be point four
or zero okay two more to go 3.27 should
we convert it to a percent or to a
fraction let's do the percent first
we're gonna move the decimal two places
to the right that's three hundred and
twenty seven percent and that's a big
percentage right and if we move it okay
to the right two places that's our
percent but now we're going to go to the
decimal form so this is really three and
twenty seven hundredths so we can you
see that decimal point you can say the
word and three whole and twenty seven
hundredths again hundreds because the
last digit here is in the hundredths
place so this is three and twenty seven
hundredths okay last example two percent
we're gonna be moving the decimal point
one two places to the left that's point
zero two okay or you can think of this
as two percent two per hundred to parts
out of a hundred which that will help us
to convert to our fraction form okay
which is one fiftieth so there you have
it so I hope you're joining these videos
if you are go ahead and subscribe to the
channel go ahead and check out some of
my past videos and I look forward to
seeing you in the next video I'll talk
to you soon